sends alberto up to that right-handed
hitter
roberto ground ball into the open right
side base hit for him whoa and it gets
by the right fielder renfro mullins will
score
alberto headed to third
and hancer is in with a single and a two
base error how about that
you know one of the achilles heels for
the raise even though they've been
playing some really good baseball has
been their defense the first half of the
season down 02 in the count here
a little tapper that should get the run
home yes
aaron throw
and nunez they throw behind him they got
him at first so the run scores nunez
trying to get a little aggressive to get
to second got caught in between and the
throw from perez gets him two down and
here's a look at asher wojciechowski's
numbers on the year
1-3 with the 484 earned run average
hasn't faced the raise yet this year you
see 21 punchouts and seven walks at
times he can lose a little bit of
command swindle up in the lineup to
third today 288 hitter three doubles
it's a pop fly short center that is
going to fall base hit
meadows
had to stop to see if it was going to be
caught
so he advances to third in second and
third and two men out for
yoshitsugo popped him up
there's the call rio ruiz hustles across
the infield makes the catch
another base hit mullen's second hit of
the game and the orioles have the first
two on to start their third inning kyle
snyder's making a trip to the mound and
he wants everybody in on this
conversation you can see him
waving everybody in so this is okay
let's straighten it up boys good pitch
away from getting out of this
runners go pitch is made and it's popped
up on the right side
joy waiting for it the rays get out of
that so a battle there between richard
and nunez
two nothing baltimore tying right at the
plate and brandon lau he skied one to
right his last time
[Applause]
again over to first paying a lot of
attention to meadows
well it's one thing keep an eye on him
but the guy at the plate with big time
power
and there's a drive
high and deep to ride and that baby is
out of here
[Music]
what a shot off the bat of brandon lau
a two-run blast his 10th home run of the
year he was taking aim at the video
board out there with that one just to
the right of it and you're worried about
the runner over there you ought to be
worried about this guy right here
with one out here is ryan mount castle
here's the 01 to mount castle it's
slowly on the ground the left side he
gets by the third baseman and kicks up
on the shortstop wendell and mount
castle is going to reach richards
against valencia
five-fly ball back into deep left center
kiermeier on the run still going back
into the deepest part of the ballpark
and it bounds over the fence which will
be a break for the reigns boy that if it
would have rattled around in that corner
you're right the run scores maybe a
runner on third but that ball bounds out
bump castle over to third for the
catcher brian holliday
[Applause]
up the middle
rays had the defense position perfectly
two men left bottom of the fourth coming
2-2 time
and second base brandon loud coming up
to that in a game that is tied at two
oh he is hit by that pitch on the first
delivery wow is hit to load the bases
yandy diaz is hitting 300.
and a high chop toward the middle
they're going to get it out at second
and that's the only one they get and the
rays score the run margot crosses the
plate to make it three to two that will
reload the bases and get caremeyer to
the plate
[Music]
and now there's a strike
and
kiermeyer appears to have an issue
come out of the game meadows at third
diaz it's second and tsutsugo at first
2-2
fastball outside corner strike three
call well the rays they get one but that
is all as castro comes on strikes out of
thomas
[Applause]
grounded into left field there's a base
hit so two out action for the orioles
and that'll get santander to the play
holy cow i don't know what diaz is
looking at down there so now alberto who
represents the tying run
is in scoring position so yet another
opportunity here's the 3-2 pitch
pace hit center field around third
alberto he'll score a little bobble out
there from
satsugo and the orioles have tied it up
with a clutch two out base hit from
anthony santander here's the catcher
michael perez brings three fly balls
tonight
he lifts it into center field mullins
will go back to the track that's got
carrie out of here
home run for michael perez
on a 2-0 pitch to the deep part of the
ballpark
and the rays take a 4-3 lead first home
run of the year for michael perez
two out nobody on the last chance for
the orioles is cedric mullins
swing and a best that takes care of
mullins and the reigns win it 4-3
castillo picks up his first save of the
year